suppose we have an object and we're
applying a constant force in the
horizontal direction we would now like
to introduce the concept of work suppose
our force starts at a point X I and goes
to a position X final and we'll call
this the I hat direction
then our force as a vector will write FX
I had and now what we'd like to
calculate is the product of force with
the displacement of the object so our
displacement vector Delta X is equal to
Delta X I hat where Delta X is equal to
X final minus X initial and for our
constant force for the case where FX is
a constant we would like to define the
work done by this force in displacing
the object from our initial position and
we'll mark it like that to the final
position here is given by the product so
we'll call work is the product of the
force FX times the displacement and so
that's equal to F X times X final minus
X initial and this is our definition for
work for the special case where the
force is constant now if we look at this
our force may in our drive diagram we
drew it in the positive x-direction but
if our force F X we're less than zero
and our displacement was in the positive
direction positive then you can see that
the work is negative so if the force is
opposing the displacement and that's
what would happen if FX was pointing in
the negative direction the work would be
negative if FX is positive and the
displacement is positive then the work
is positive so we see work is a
scaler that has assigned quantity
positive or negative now whenever we
introduce a new quantity we always have
to be a little bit careful about the
units since work is the product of force
and distance then our SI units for work
are the units of force which are newtons
times the units of distance meters and
we call this a Joule
so one Joule is equal to one Newton
meter now graphically we can make an
interpretation of this let's draw a
graph of force the X component of the
force and here if we had some origin
we'll have X and our object is starting
at X I and it's going to X final and
throughout this process we're assuming
that the force is constant so what we
see in this diagram here I'll just shade
in this area that our work which was the
product of force times the displacement
corresponds to the area here so we have
a geometric interpretation of work as
the area under the force verse position
graph and this is our example of work
for a constant force